bienvenido al nivel 2 de ecuaciones
lineales así que vamos a hacer un
ejemplo yo tengo la siguiente ecuación 2
x 3 esto lo quiero ser igual a menos 15
y bueno como resuelvo esta ecuación
lineal y las respuestas bastante
sencillas para resolver este 4 lineal lo
primero que hay que hacer es dejar todo
lo que tiene que ver con las variables
de un lado de la ecuación y todo lo que
tiene que ver con los números del otro
lado de la ecuación es decir como
queremos despejar la x que es lo que nos
estorba y aquí nos damos cuenta que lo
primero que podemos quitar es este 3
este 3 está sumando a la equis por lo
tanto para pasarlo del otro lado de la
ecuación lo que tengo que hacer es
eliminarlo o cancelarlo de este lado de
la ecuación y para esto lo que voy a
hacer es restar tres de ambos lados de
la ecuación menos 3 aquí y menos 3
también del otro lado de la ecuación
recuerdan que lo que haga de un lado de
la ecuación lo tengo que hacer también
del otro lado de la ecuación y bueno
menos tres más tres se van se cancelan
porque esto me da 0 2 x 0 pues es 2x y
del otro lado me va a quedar menos 15
menos 3 así que déjenme apuntarlo
date cuenta que para eliminar este +3 lo
que hicimos fue restar 3 de ambos lados
de la ecuación y me queda 2x esto es
igual a menos 15
3 - 15 menos 3 es menos 18 2 x igual a
menos 18 bueno ya tengo esta ecuación y
si te das cuenta este es justo el tipo
de ecuaciones que resolvemos en el vídeo
pasado en el vídeo pasado teníamos
ecuaciones muy parecidas a esto y para
resolver este tipo de cuestiones lo que
hacíamos era multiplicar por el inverso
multiplicativo que el inverso
multiplicativo de 2 es un medio entonces
multiplicó el medio por esto y
multiplicó un medio también del lado
derecho de la ecuación un medio por 2
esto es lo mismo que 12 por 12 entre 2
por 12 es decir 11 x x x lo que estoy
haciendo es cancelando este 2 con su
inverso multiplicativo y ya tengo
despejada x la izquierda de la ecuación
mientras que del lado derecho tengo
menos 18 entre 2 lo cual es menos 9 y
perfecto ya encuentra el resultado
x igual a menos 9 es el resultado de
éste
y para comprobarlo vamos a sustituir el
valor de x igual a menos 9 en nuestra
ecuación original para ver que realmente
llegamos a lo correcto 2 x menos 9 + 3
ojo x vale menos 9 y 2 x menos 9 es
menos 18 más 3 y menos 18 más 3 es menos
15 y menos 15 pues es igual a menos 15
que es justo lo que queríamos así que ya
tenemos uno de estos ejercicios y vamos
por el siguiente el cual voy a meter
fracciones para que es un ejercicio un
poco más peludo y un poco más difícil de
resolver sin embargo no te espantes me
voy a tomar a menos un medio de x ya
esto le voy a sumar tres cuartos esto
tiene que ser igual a cinco sextos y
bueno si más o menos tienes una idea de
qué es lo que sigue estás en muy buen
momento para pausar el vídeo e intentar
hacerlo por ti mismo porque a partir de
ahorita voy a buscar la solución de este
problema que por cierto la solución de
este problema lo primero que voy a hacer
es pasar este de tres cuartos del otro
lado con signo negativo o dicho de otra
manera lo que voy a hacer es restar
menos tres cuartos de ambos lados
menos tres cuartos más esto y del otro
lado cinco sextos - tres cuartos
y bueno menos tres cuartos más tres
cuartos se cancelan se eliminan y me
queda menos un medio de equis y después
del lado derecho de la ecuación me queda
cinco sextos menos tres cuartos
esta es una resta de fracciones así que
el mínimo común múltiplo de 6 y 4 es 12
y después digo 12 entre 62 2 por 5 es 10
y después menos 2 entre 4 es 33 por 39
entonces nos queda 10 menos 9 todo esto
sobre 12 y bueno me queda menos un medio
de x es igual a 10 menos 9 lo cual es 11
sobre 12 un doceavo perfecto ya tengo
esto de aquí lo único que hice fue una
resta de fracciones ahora lo que quiero
que veas es que también tenemos que
eliminar este menos un medio date cuenta
que otra vez estamos en el nivel 1 para
eliminar este menos un medio lo que hay
que hacer es multiplicar por su inverso
multiplicativo pero cuál es el inverso
multiplicativo de menos un medio pues es
menos 2 o dicho de otra manera menos 2
1 pero ojo lo que estoy haciendo de un
lado de la ecuación lo tengo que hacer
también del otro lado de la ecuación por
lo tanto también aquí tengo que poner x
menos 2 sobre uno menos 2 sobre 1 x
menos un medio estos dos se cancelan me
queda x mientras que del otro lado de la
ecuación me queda menos 2 doceavos que
por cierto esto es lo mismo que menos un
sexto x vale menos un sexto y esa es la
solución de esta ecuación ahora bien
sería bastante bueno que lo
comprobaremos y para eso déjenme copiar
la cuestión original y voy a sustituir a
x por el valor del menos un sexto es
decir me queda menos un medio que
multiplica a su vez a x que es menos un
sexto menos un medio que multiplica
menos un sexto más tres cuartos vamos a
ver cuánto es esto menos x menos me da
más uno por uno me da uno y dos por seis
me da 12 un doceavo un doceavo más tres
cuartos cuántos no seamos más tres
cuartos bueno esta es una suma de
fracciones cuyo común denominador es 12
así que 12 entre 12 a 1 por 11 2 entre
43 por 39 me quedan 10 12 ambos lo
cuales 5 sextos que es justo lo que
queríamos llegar esta era mi solución
todo lo demás lo escribí después esto es
lo que yo tenía en un inicio en ecuación
original 5 sextos y perfecto hemos
acabado el nivel 2 de ecuaciones
lineales y si te das cuenta ya estoy
preparado para hacer ecuaciones de este
estilo que por cierto la única
diferencia entre el nivel 1 y el nivel 2
es que en este nivel tenemos un
coeficiente que está sumando o está
restando a nuestra ecuación el cual hay
que cancelar para que nos quede de nuevo
una ecuación del nivel 1